[Music]
in our special series school matters as
parents work to keep their kids
education on track many are also
focusing on their children's mental
health
the american academy of pediatrics says
that since the start of the pandemic
in march 14 of parents reported
worsening behavioral health
for their kids across the country 73
percent of school districts offer social
and emotional learning programs
which have now been linked to improved
behavior relationships and your grades
too
dr tara narula reports those programs
may be needed now
more than ever take a deep breath
jet home starts every school day with a
mantra
may i be happy along with reading
writing and math
jet is learning about feelings it's all
part of something called
ruler a curriculum used at 2500 schools
around the country all emotions affect
our attention or capacity
mark brackett developed the program at
yale university
emotions matter for everything if we
can't manage our feelings
it's hard to be creative and it's hard
to focus
in his book permission to feel brackett
outlines five steps
for mastering emotions recognizing
understanding labeling expressing
regulating emotions are a lot more
complex than just being like oh like i'm
happy right now or i'm sad
the hardest part is recognizing how you
feel ruler uses a color-coded tool to
help students
identify their feelings we ask students
from new york's lab school
to show us how it works when i'm feeling
red
i feel like an intense anger and
frustration
when i'm feeling yellow i feel super
happy
and super energized blue sad
and overwhelmed green tranquil and
relaxed
i do a world by langston hughes because
of the pandemic
leslie gill and her sister lauren aren't
able to practice the ruler concepts as
they usually do
with their classmates you have to write
about how you think the other person
feels so then you see the different
perspectives
because you might be thinking that this
person feels one way but
it's actually they feel like the
opposite
it is very important for us to not
assume how kids are feeling we do that
all the time
and what research shows is that we often
make a lot of mistakes
why is social emotional learning so
critical
particularly when we're living through a
pandemic
we're feeling the strongest emotions we
might have ever had before
my research with children shows that
they're frustrated
they're overwhelmed they're anxious
they're bored they're lonely me and my
brother will fight a lot um especially
during quarantine
stepping back and like thinking about
what i'm saying and how i'm feeling has
definitely helped me
i've been like struggling i've been like
stressed out we're in a global pandemic
you don't have to
like be like perfect parents are also
offered ruler training to reinforce what
their children learn at school
first day out in over a month
it's helping jet and his family navigate
the pandemic together
as a male i was kind of raised to not
be emotional these kids are being
introduced at a young
age and they they're able to define
their
feelings and their emotions and it took
me
years of therapy to
what do you think parents could do a
better job at
in terms of talking to their kids about
their emotions
the best way to make teenagers feel
comfortable opening up
about their emotions as if you guys do
the same so i hope parents know that
they can
be vulnerable too we as parents don't
have to have all the answers
we just have to be compassionate
we have to ask the questions and guide
our children
dr taran narula joins us now tara this
is such a great idea i love what jet's
parents said
so many people are raised not to express
their emotions so what can parents do
isn't it hard for them to sometimes know
if their kids are struggling and what
can they do about that
absolutely gail and it's so important
and we spoke to dr brackett about that
who you saw in the piece and there were
a couple things he recommended the first
is really being a role model for your
kids
that even when you think they're not
listening and watching you they
are they're seeing how you react to your
anxieties your stresses your fears and
your mistakes
so you can be vulnerable but you can
also teach them strategies that are
healthy
to deal with their feelings the second
is as he said don't assume what your
child is feeling
behavior does not equal emotion so just
because your child looks calm
doesn't mean they may be feeling that
way just because your child
storms out of the room and says i hate
you mom it may be that they're not
really angry maybe they're disappointed
at a failure that happened at school
maybe they had a fight with their friend
so really important to sit down talk to
your kid ask them how they're feeling
and listen to what they have to say so
important thank you tara